you don't care if people die
you don't care people die
close don't you lie please
[Applause]
people die
[Music]
you don't care people die
universe
people die
you don't care if people die
you don't care people died
people die
[Music]
you don't care people died
you don't care people die
tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't care
enough
[Applause]
translations
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
drinks translations
videos
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
again
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
will never be divided for people United
United will never be dividing the people
United will never be divided to people
United will never be divided for the
people United will never be divided the
people United will never find it the
people United will never be divided to
the people United will never be your
mind the people the United will never be
divided
tonight
the people invited
the people United will never be divided
to the people United will better be
alive
the people we met will never need your
mind the people tonight
[Applause]
go away
foreign
[Applause]
hey hey
yourself
[Applause]
tell me questions
[Music]
[Applause]
now with Patrick
star
[Applause]
ches
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so in other words
[Music]
gays and I just gotta sit here and let
that happening
area
it's just wrong
[Music]
you yeah
[Applause]
please pause
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
too much move let's move
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
now
[Music]
Instagram
serious
[Music]
how many more years
[Applause]
[Music]
he would be on our side I love everyone
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
I love everyone
[Applause]
perceptions
[Music]
[Applause]
trans Unborn